[Musique]
les gelés matinales sont bien de retour
dans les Yvelines le premier weekend de
janvier sera froid surtout à partir de
dimanche météo France annonce entre 0 et
1°r en moyenne sur l'ensemble du
département mais c'est surtout la
semaine prochaine que les températures
vont chuter lundi il fera jusqu'à -5° à
rambouiller et Houdan - 4° à manentel
jolie et Versailles et les températures
continueront d'être négative tout au
long de la semaine la raison de l'air
polaire en provenance d'Europe du Nord
et de Russie se dirige vers la France
alors petit conseil couvrez-vous bien
écharpe bonnet gants seront de rigueur
et le froid les fera peut-être partir
les chenilles processionnaires se
montrent exceptionnellement tôt cette
saison dans les yelin habituellement ces
insectes ne sont visibles qu' printemps
au mois d'avril mais certains ivelinois
ont déjà constaté leur retour dans les
forêts et les jardin pour rappel ces
chenilles sont hurtiquantes et
présentent un risque sanitaire important
avec notamment des démangeaisons des
réactions cutanées ou encore des
allergies elles peuvent également être
mortelles pour les chiens et les chats
mais alors comment lutter contre leur
prolifération si vous envoyer
rapprochez-vous d'un professionnel il
pourra mettre en place un traitement
phytosanitaire ou un piège autour du
Tron d'arbre concerné du sport à présent
et plus particulièrement du cyclisme
jusqu'au dimanche 7 janvier le vélodrome
national de c-quentin en Newlin
accueille les championnats de France de
cyclisme sur piste une compétition
importante juste avant les Jeux
olympiques de Paris 2024 plus de 140
athlètes venant de toute la France vont
se disputer les titres nationaux
aujourd'hui avaient lieu les épreuves de
poursuite par équipe mais aussi
l'épreuve de vitesse pour les femmes
demain les coureurs s'affronteront sur
l'Omnium une compétition en quatre
épreuves qui récompense le cycliste le
plus endurant enfin ce weekend auront
lieu la poursuite individuelle l'AM
amécain le kine et la course au point le
point d'org vendredi à 17h pour l'é
preuve de vitesse chez les hommes tous
les jours des médailles seront décernés
enfin on termine par une information
insolite il a 77 ans et il sera pour la
32e fois au départ du rally Dakar ce
vendredi 5 janvier originaire de Chatou
Jean-Pierre strugau est le doyen de la
course il participe avec la team MD
rally sport au volant d'un buggy pour en
arriver là il a fallu comme tous les ans
franchira déjà un certain nombre
d'obstacles c'est-à-dire va d'abord
avoir arrivver à un certain âge laavale
du corps médical et puis
surtout obtenir
l'accord familial merci Marie de me
laisser une nouvelle fois partir je sais
que tu es un peu inquiète mais il y a
pas lieu je serais prudent et et je vais
assurer comme tous les ans le septuagén
se prépare toute l'année à cette course
mythique qu'il ne louperait pour rien au
monde son objectif cette année arrivé
dans les 30 premiers il faut croire que
cette course dans le désert
conserve